so this is a video that I can't quite
believe I'm making
some backstory for the past several
years I've had a Discord where people
who like my videos and my live streams
can chat to each other and share
interesting articles and pictures of
their Warhammer and memes and that kind
of thing there has been a really
long-running joke in this Discord that
at some point in the future I'm going to
run an event called Clark con and it's
going to be at like the London Excel
Center and it's giving me this vast
narcissistic celebration of everything
that I do and people have made like you
know joke posters and Joker genders for
this event but earlier this year I went
to one of the dates on Carrie Hope
Fletcher's UK tour if you don't know who
she is she's a fantastic YouTuber and
singer in the West End and she was doing
this live show which was a mix of a
little bit of personal stuff and some
Recollections and talking about her
books and a lot of music and musical
theater because that's what she does
professionally so I was sat in the
audience in the interval and I put out
an Instagram poll asking if I did an
event like this in the southwest of the
UK would you be interested in coming and
hundreds of people said yes so
um
I guess we're doing Clark it's not
called Clark I refuse to call it that in
this video I am officially announcing
Simon cycom Khan yes I know the name is
ridiculous no point if you get the
reference super brief summary the event
is here in bath and it's taking place on
Sunday the 3rd of September it's an
afternoon event and tickets are
available right now at a link in the
description for 10 pounds with that
money basically just covering the cost
of hiring the venue and a few other
expenses so what are we doing basically
I know what I want the event to not be I
don't want it to be Clark Khan I don't
want it to be all about me I want it to
be about two things firstly as the name
suggests this is an event about science
communication that means that I am going
to give a couple of talks about what I
do like the stuff I talk about and how I
talk about it and why I think science
communication is important but it also
means celebrating cycom in other formats
so one of the other sessions we're
running in the afternoon is an hour of
lightning talks from researchers in this
community they're each gonna have three
minutes and one slide to tell you about
their research across a huge range of
subjects another session is going to be
an Interactive science-based ttf PG one
shot run by my friends and fellow
science and tabletop nerds the RP Geeks
I hope the event is going to be an
interesting mix of entertaining and
informative about a range of subjects in
science but with some emphasis on the
stuff I mostly talk about in my videos
so about climate but the second thing I
want this event to be is an opportunity
to meet people and yeah that's
absolutely going to include me and some
of the people that I regularly stream
with you're definitely going to have a
chance to chat to Me For Better or For
Worse but also a chance to meet other
people in this community if you're in
the Discord it'll be a chance to put
some faces to usernames and even if
you're not it will be an opportunity to
meet people with some shared interests
so if you like the sound of an afternoon
learning interesting things about
science learning about science
communication and meeting interesting
people with shared interests and
reflecting I guess on how far you and
people in this community have come in
the past 12 years
linked tickets is down there in the
description just a note this is a
relatively small event there's only a
hundred tickets and if there is for some
reason huge demand for this then maybe I
could look into doing more events in the
future but for now I've never done
anything like this before I'm keeping
this simple keeping it small keeping it
local
if traveling for this is just out of the
question for you then let me know you're
interested down in the comments let me
know where you are
and who knows maybe I could do more
events like this elsewhere it is
entirely mad to me by the way that even
a small event like this is a possibility
over the past 12 years I've gone from
speaking to a few dozen people about
Oxbridge admissions to hundreds of
thousands of people about climate change
and speaking at new scientists live and
lecturing about science communication at
certain I've not lost sight of how mad
that is and how lucky I am and how
privileged I am to be in this situation
so if you've watched my videos over the
past 12 years I just want to take this
opportunity to say thank you for Lifting
me to where I am now and if you'd like
to be part of a celebration I guess of
that journey and much more besides then
it would be really great to see you this
September in bath once again linked
tickets is down there in the description
that's it for me for now though I will
say there is another video coming out
late to this week with Believe It or Not
Another really exciting announcement and
looking a bit further ahead another
really cool video out later this month
but for now thank you for watching this
far I hope to see you in bath this
September and if not I'll see you in the
next one